we have broken down
case growth rates
by political orientation we found oh wow
red counties have a dramatically higher
case rate
than blue counties
we've looked at it every way sliced and
diced it there is a new study which is
now looking at
what states have more than the average
number of cases and what states or which
states as some may prefer
have
fewer than the national average of cases
of the 23 states with above average
coveted cases
21
voted for trump
now this is state by state we could do
this county by by county we could do
this in other ways
a business insider article
there's a significant political divide
in how u.s states are dealing with the
pandemic and red states are faring much
worse according to the washington post
report
states that backed trump in the most
recent election have higher rates of
covet cases and deaths than those that
voted biden not surprising but look at
the degree to which this is true
of the 23 states that have a total of
new coveted cases per capita
above the national ratio
washington post says 21 of them voted
for trump in november 21
out of 23 of the above average coveted
states voted trump now interestingly
hawaii and georgia are the only biden
states with more cases per capita than
the average
hawaii is an exception in a sense
because you have people from all over
the country going to hawaii for
vacations and
it's not clear what effect that's having
but at least one of the two exceptions
to the 21 out of 23
seems to have a sort of travel related
situation that is specific
a similar statistic applies when it
comes to the number of deaths of the 18
states with new death tolls higher than
the national ratio
14 of those voted for the former
president donald trump
when it comes to the 17 least vaccinated
states 16 all but georgia
voted for trump
this is math guys now there is a there's
been an attempted rebuttal at this data
which says
you also need to
equalize
for
population density
and i've looked at those analyses which
say that it's much more even where is it
worse is it worse in red versus blue
sort of trying to point to a different
factor
it's not convincing based on everything
i've read
when when you look at a county level
analysis
when you look at a state level analysis
no matter how you slice and dice it it
is abundantly clear that the group that
is most against the vaccine is trump
voting republicans
and the places with more trump voting
republicans
are the places that disproportionately
have more cases and have more deaths now
i know some of you might say david david
david hold on don't
remember it was new york it was
massachusetts it was california
this was an early result
before we knew anything about the virus
about the fact that the places with the
most direct flights to the places that
had early cases asia
and europe
were the hardest hit early but when you
look at the numbers once vaccinations
started once we understood what
guidelines worked once we understood how
things worked uh it is overwhelmingly
worse in the places with a lot of
republicans who aren't getting
vaccinated it doesn't matter how you
slice and dice the data
are there people
so deluded
that they want to get coveted
in order to make biden look worse are
there people who think you know what if
i get it that'll be another case and
that'll make biden look bad is it does
anybody know has anybody come across
people matching that description if so i
want to hear about it but the numbers
are humiliating they're humiliating in
terms of cases they're humiliating in
terms of vaccines now the what's the
upshot
it looks like
in the same way as europe is starting to
get over the delta wave
i'm hopeful because remember i i don't
for me this is just about health it's
not about who could look good or bad
based on where no
it looks as though numbers are leveling
off and cases are even down about seven
percent over the last 10 days or so
let's hope it continues uh the vaccine
quote mandates from joe biden
will take some time to have an effect
but hopefully they will and we will be
tracking it all for you let me know
what's going on in your state you can
find me on twitter deepakman uh and send
me your thoughts one of our sponsors is
four sigmatic the company best known for
their delicious mushroom coffee four
sigmatics mushroom coffee is organic
fair trade single origin arabica coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies i've been drinking
four sigmatic coffee a lot lately it
actually doesn't taste anything like
mushrooms it just tastes like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling or a midday crash and they have
over 20 000 five-star reviews and best
of all if you don't love it you'll get
100 percent of your money back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 percent off and free shipping when
you go to four sigmatic dot com slash
pacman the link is right underneath this
video